in season two obviously we see your
characters learning from what they
experienced in season one and applying
it to how they survived but what about
you two as actors what's an example of
you know like a like a filming tip or
trick especially for filming on location
that you learned in season one that made
filming season two a little easier this
time around oh bug spray
that's what
that's what i always had uh because
didn't jenna ended up having a leech on
her shoe
um and i had a leak on her shoe yeah so
i had learned that about coming on
location that's right i think it was on
her shoe
yeah i know right
and then her
uh jenna and sarah took a picture with
the leech on jenna's shoe as one would
that was the smart move
they're pretty fascinating
um
i
think
something i've learned about shooting on
location is that um
i mean it's like it's important to get a
good night's sleep um
i don't know even after those long days
sometimes i found myself
like i guess wired or just wanting to
have
um
like time to myself at the end of the
night so i would stay up way past my
bedtime um but it does really help when
you're in the elements i mean it's just
not only are you outside all day but you
also have to you know do your job and
and fulfill what the character needs in
that moment
um and just making sure that you're as
as ready as you can be to do that
i feel like that applies to like any job
out there yeah i should take that advice
to heart that kind of paves the way into
my next question for you sarah i mean
this is the highest compliment but i
don't think there's any tv series
character who stresses me out more than
leah like she's
at an 11 non-stop so i guess what is the
key to doing all of that and keeping the
bar that high in that respect but
without burning yourself out you know to
be honest i think
playing this character has
unlocked a new sense of anxiety for me
because her heart is raising all the
time um
but i think it's
like when you really think about what
she's going through and what all the
girls are going through and then
the
the crushing
realization that no one really believes
her or understands what she's trying to
communicate with about what she believes
is happening on this island
when that comes into the the reality of
of as the actor i think it sort of just
makes it would make anybody
you know on edge and wired and
um
yeah it just sort of informs itself i
think um
and then
but at the end of the day it's the
performances that everyone else is
you know giving
themselves to that that make the
that make leah's cr you know seem as um
i guess neurotic at times as she is um
you know
she wouldn't seem i think as neurotic if
it weren't for the reactions that and
the ripple effects that it has on on
everyone else in the island i have a
million uh follow-up questions but we
will wait for spoilers for that before
we get there though
rain for you it kind of feels to me a
little bit like not only are you playing
your own character this season but
you're also kind of responsible for
keeping nora's influence alive
throughout as well so what is the key to
doing what you need to do with rachel
but also i guess kind of tapping into
the importance that character played in
season one and beyond when she's not
physically there yeah i think um
obviously still remembering and roman
key moments and special moments between
nora and and rachel from season one
but also um i think just for me i have
sisters myself so to kind of
somewhat walk a fine line of living in
that world of imagining them not being
with me is i think something anybody can
relate to like when you when you have
siblings um or just someone that you
love dearly to
[Music]
the fear of them not being there and so
i think that's how i played with rachel
of really just coping and dealing with
that uh throughout the entire season and
that's the way you kind of like i was
keeping nora alive as well as the the
writing was giving me that as well all
especially well done all right i'm
putting up the spoiler warning now so i
can dig into some stuff talk about
everything freely we will label
everything appropriately
sarah what was it like finding out that
you were going to be able to film with
ben folds
yeah that was such a surprise i mean i
i had listened to ben folds music um
yeah i was familiar and then just having
the
i mean such a change to it it was such a
change to work on those scenes not only
was it different in
in leah's
uh
mindset you know was very heightened but
just like the tone of everything and
working with ben who
you know hadn't been hadn't done the
season before or
the six or so episodes leading up to
that with us it just struck a totally
different tone
um it's it was just this weird dream
like space um
and that was really interesting to
inhabit um just because it was also like
divorced from the rest of the experience
in the sense of
um
having like working with someone new who
hadn't
um done the rest of the season with us
um yeah it was awesome it was really
cool to hear and play the music live
like he there was a grand piano in the
sand and
i had like a mini benfold's like private
concert
this video
and usually so amazing
just wanted to like say that she does
amazing in those scenes they were really
really great they were very very i was
like tickled when he first appeared on
screen i'm like no way they're doing it
and then like you went hard into it and
it's very effective um another spoiler
one for you sarah so
i like i know you probably don't know
what the future holds for the show just
yet but for you just in terms of being
able to shoot that final moment of
season two where is leah's head at for
you because we don't get to spend too
much time with her but like like my god
that is a guttural and very loaded
scream at the end so is that a moment of
i guess expressing you know frustration
and loss of hope or more like like a
battle cry where like you did this to me
again and i'm gonna get you kind of
thing i guess it's probably a hybrid i
think that
moment um
it's really that whole episode i think
leads up to it's the first time that
leah has really had like assurances that
she
is right it's not that she just has like
feeling deep in her stomach that that
instinct that
um
that is so alive inside of her um
but it's the first time that you know
she's she's finally caught gretchen and
she has she's in control of this racing
mind and it's helped her figure it out
and i think it's in that she's so used
to things like falling through her hands
like she she gets like 90 of it right in
the first season and parts of the second
season it's just like
that 10 that she gets wrong
that's why it slips away from her that's
why she can't convince the group that's
why she can't convince fatten
um
but that she wasn't wrong this time and
she had a plan and then somehow they
were still just like a half a step ahead
of her and i think it's that like
deep deep frustration that it wasn't my
fault this time it was
yeah it's it's like i can't it's just
not right like it
i there's there's so many moments in
life like that where you're like oh god
it's not that i wasn't prepared i did
all this
i did all of it right and then yet
somehow
i failed i feel for her but it means i
get more of the show so it's fine and
i'd be more bummed that they're kicking
me out and i don't get to ask rayne my
spoiler questions right now but i think
we get to talk again soon so brace
yourself i got a long list of them
huge congratulations and thank you for
season two i loved it yet again
thank you guys thank you
you